[Music]
trump
i remember when he said if you're a
billionaire
women let you grab them by the [__]
checks out i don't don't get me wrong i
know there's women in here who are like
that's [__] up that's [__]
i would never allow that and to you i
would say
you've never met a billionaire
he's got nothing to do with you you're
out there getting fingered by
thousands
it's a different demographic
[Music]
and frankly i agree with you a thousand
there should ask you permission
before he puts his minimum wage fingers
in your [__] that's disgusting that's
why your [__] smells like wendy's
but a billionaire let him grab your
[__]
a billionaire grabs your [__] that's
the best thing that's happened to you in
your life
you're gonna sue that guy and now you're
a millionaire
fastest million dollars you've ever made
okay you know how many billionaires
there are in the world
it's like a hundred any one of them
could grab my
dick anyway
let bill gates walk up to me right now
grab my dick i'll grab his wrist and
hold that [__] down
yeah bill i'll show you microsoft
look
[Applause]
dude if you really think it's a job just
look at him right look at obama when
that guy got elected
he looked like he was about 41 years old
when he left
office that guy looked like he was about
right look at michelle
she looks younger now than she did when
that dude got elected
[Applause]
what has she done for the last eight
years
yeah other than laying a giant vat of
illuminati level lotion
just sit here floating
a couple hours a shapeshifter comes in
and dumps another bucket on here
she pops her head up hey bam bam tell
stevie wonder to come down
and play some songs tonight
now i found out she's doing a tour
because uh she's doing a book tour
yeah she wrote a book she wrote a book
about not having a job
i gotta read that [__] book
chapter one how to know if a dick tastes
presidential
how to weed your way
how to weed your way through all that
local representative [__] and get to the
big swinging dick in the room
i'll tell you right now say what you
want about republican presidents but
they got their first ladies in line
they do dude george w
was president for eight years eight
years
i don't even know his wife's name
oh is it abigail or some [__] maggie no
clue
donald trump's wife stands behind him
like a giant meer cat like
bill clinton was president and his wife
never shut up i want to do healthcare
he [__] around on her so much he's
like all right whatever just do it
but i'm telling you right now i'm gonna
i'm gonna check out that [__] tour
i got to see what that's all about you
know who opens
who opens on that [__] tour was it
oprah winfrey's husband
you know
does he [__] come out and talk about
what it's like to walk her dogs
i do it for 20 minutes a day the carcass
spaniel is probably the most fussiest
and i get to bring him around
look i'm sure that there's some uh
feminists in the crowd right now not
appreciating this joke feeling
triggered feeling like they need to
[__] put out a hashtag
or some [__] and be brave and speak out
you know what you're full of [__]
you are all
all those feminists are full of [__]
because i'm going to tell you right now
someday
someday there's going to be there's
going to be the first woman president
all right which means which you don't
even know what you don't get what a
[__] platform is
and you automatically cheer
it's got the same genitalia
[__] i'm telling you they're not
smart people feminists
are not as smart as they're coming off
i'm telling you
someday this couldn't be
by the way it's gonna be my last show
ever by the time this [__] thing
comes up
someday there's gonna be the first
female president which means
there's gonna be the first male first
lady
all right and you wait you [__]
wait the first time that dude opens his
mouth about some political [__]
you watch all these feminists they're on
me you shut the [__] up
you shut the [__] up it is her time now
it is her time she was elected not you
go pick out some plates [__] you are
the first
lady
probably just say it but there's a
reason for that because it matters more
for that matters more black people see
see even when i vote right which i don't
but but
but even when i like think about like
who i would vote for
right i don't even look at their
political policies
i just look at their character
you know what i'm saying now you gotta
read now i'm serious you gotta read
between the lines like you know you look
at clinton and black people like clinton
we've seen him on the campaign that's
all one thing on the campaign trail he
he actually just picked the black baby
up and kicked him come here little
[__] baby
i like that he did not hesitate or
nothing
you see george bush junior
like say i'd never vote for george bush
junior but i don't know george was doing
his politics
only thing i know about george bush jr
is that that guy
sniffed cocaine that's right now listen
we cannot
have that [__] in the white house that
might be fine for a mayor
but god dammit not knowing i'm saying
the states are too high in the white
house can't have no coke here president
he'd be selling nuclear seekers for 20
dollars and [__]
could be in meetings embarrassing
america come on
sign the treaty baby i suck your dick
like what
mr president that is not how we do
business here sir
stop sucking the ambassador's death
okay no let them finish
i will sign the treaty
there will be peace in israel finally
at the white house this week president
clinton officially came out
against same-sex marriages what's more
the president said he is not too crazy
about opposite-sex marriages either
[Applause]
so are we still excited about barack
obama
see every black person in here should be
clapping
because we got to ride that [__] till
the wheels fall off
[Applause]
you know if that [__] don't work the
minute we go to work white folks is
looking at us like
hm you picked him
i can't wait till he runs for his second
term man because that was the most
exciting part about the political
process to me was the campaign
because you knew at some point he was
supposed to win he had all the right
ingredients that came together at the
right time
he's tall good looking articulate highly
intelligent
you know smooth under pressure
charismatic and most importantly
he was the right shade
he made white people feel comfortable
because y'all know if that [__] was
bernie mac black
or precious purple he wouldn't want
he's like coffee with cream it goes down
easy
you ever have coffee black is too strong
america is not ready for ooh they not
ready yet
[Music]
and he had 97 of the black vote 97
which means he had black people online
we were like a hand and a glove we were
tied together
but he still couldn't become president
without white people so for the white
people that voted for him
i thank you because you helped make
history
but some of y'all are starting to get a
little impatient and your racism is
seeping out a little bit
you say [__] when you're frustrated i
thought you [__] are fast what's
taking so long
took eight years to [__] this country up
it's gonna take a second to get it
together relax
you got a lot of tough [__] you got to
deal with man like the big controversy
right now they talking about that mosque
near september 11th a lot of people
upset about that
you know september 11 just rolled around
every year we got to relive that
[__]
but there was a bright side man you know
september 11 blacks and whites came
together like never before
because after september 11 arabs took
all the pressure off us
i'm telling you they are the new [__]
it's amazing
i get on a plane now white people y'all
be happy to see us dude bro come here
here sit next to me man right here here
hold my daughter
i love you [__] come here we got to
watch out for those [__] for shizzle
nizzle
huh we've bonded now that's good
and i realized certain aspects of that
[__] just affected people differently
like when the anthrax thing happened
white people y'all was very nervous
y'all would come up to me at work and
warn me like oh my god
that's how white people get when they
get dramatic oh my god
ares be careful don't open your mail
i'll tell you some black people was
never worried about anthrax
cause y'all know half this hand we don't
open up mail no way
we think that [__] is a bill we might
hold it to the light like no that's the
red notes
[__] that you want to get us with
anthrax put this [__] in the jz cd
that's how you get up i got that new
[__]
oh [__] osama got me [__]
track 12 [__] be careful track 12
more oj simpson news
on friday the juice officially endorsed
bill clinton for president
adding adding quote i'd like to help him
any way i can
to which the president replied well
there is
one thing
[Applause]
or is the trump castle it was called uh
i don't know where that is now
yeah i think they changed the name i did
i worked at trump castle
and uh i i remember just watching people
i never really been down there before
and i'm just watching these [__] old
ladies
from around the country come on buses
like from the middle of ohio or kentucky
literally yeah you see a bus that says
like lexington kentucky
[Music]
and they [__] and these [__] old
women come
out of the bus and there are like they
took a
medical hit from the trip like you just
see them
and they get out of these [__] buses
there they were in for hours days
yeah blood just clotting in their legs
you know the 60 year olds helping the 70
year olds off the bus
and they go get [__] rooms yeah and then
they pour
buckets of [__] coins all of their
[__] retirement all they got left
they just
pour it in buckets into these machines
and then they leave and then
so i'm watching all this and it's all
says trump all over it and i never and
then i was in an elevator and
trump got on with marla maples at the
time
okay and everyone was like oh there they
are they were really excited they saw
them
all oh my god there's trump and the
woman he's [__] illicitly
and they get on the elevator and uh
trump looked miserable i was in the
elevator alone with him just
by chance and he just looked miserable
he looked so unhappy
yeah and all that money i realize
there's a weird like he
has all this billions of dollars but
he's [__] miserable
because he needs a hundred billion to
look in the mirror
and not want to kill himself he needs
that these old ladies from kentucky they
don't need anything they have like maybe
a thousand dollars in the bank
right it's like they're coming it's like
a religion like they're coming to help
him
feel better like giving money giving him
the money
he's like i have a hundred billion
dollars and i don't [__]
[__] everybody it's not enough and these
old ladies are like i have maybe a
thousand you could have all of it
i'll give you all of it i'll take a bus
all day to give it to you